it is hard to find comfortable t-shirts
shirts made of supima cotton are the
softest you will find under one percent
of t-shirts are made with supima cotton
and the Leisure of NYC is the place to
find them you'll get 15 off their silky
smooth t-shirts and boxers at
davidpackman.com
NYC the link is down below
sadly we start today with a tale of
stochastic terrorism perpetrated by the
twice indicted twice impeached failed
former president you know the guy I'm
talking about the guy who's orange Trump
posted Barack Obama's address or what he
believed to be Barack Obama's address or
what was supposedly Barack Obama's
address and even though it wasn't an
armed man showed up and prosecutors now
know all about it the Associated Press
reports Trump posted what he said was
Obama's address an armed man was soon
arrested there and the question I have
for you as we read through this is did
Trump know exactly what he was doing
former president Donald Trump posted on
a social media platform what he claimed
was the home address of former president
Barack Obama
on the same day a man with guns in his
van was arrested near the property
Federal prosecutors said Wednesday
revealing you details about the case the
individual is a 37 year old Taylor
taranto who prosecutors say participated
in the January 6 riots on January 6 2021
he kept two firearms and hundreds of
rounds of ammunition inside a van he
drove across country and had been living
in according to the justice department
motion that seeks to keep him behind
bars on the day of his June 29 arrest
prosecutors said taranto reposted a
truth social post from Trump containing
What Trump claimed was Barack Obama's
home address in a post on telegram
taranto wrote quote we got these losers
surrounded see you in hell podestas and
Obamas that's a reference to John
podesta who chaired Hillary's 2016
campaign taranto also told followers on
his YouTube live stream he was looking
to get a quote good angle on a shot good
angle on a shot
Federal Defender representing taranto
did not immediately return a phone
message seeking comment but emotions
seeking to have him released pending
trial
um the lawyer wrote that her in Emotion
the lawyer wrote taranto is not a Flight
Risk and he served in Iraq okay
um all right so does Trump know exactly
what he's doing when he does this sort
of thing I believe that the term
stochastic terrorism applies here
stochastic terrorism is a technical term
that is the epitome of what we are
seeing here when we say stochastic
terrorism what we mean is when public
figures or media Outlets sometimes it
will be Fox News or others they can
Inspire seemingly random acts of
violence by spreading hateful or
extremist messages to a large enough
audience that is likely to be receptive
to it and it is historically outside of
any legal liability
so I'll give you an example in fact we
we have real life examples this guy
Glenn Beck right wing nut I think he has
a show now on the blaze or one of these
right-wing online things he used to be a
Fox News host he used to be a CNN host
okay for a while he would rant and Rave
about an organization called The Tides
foundation and he would say it's just a
horrible organization I don't even
remember at this point it's been so long
what it was that was so bad about the
tides Foundation but he would rant and
rant and rant he never directed any
particular person to go and do anything
to the tides Foundation but given that
the audience of Glenn Mac Beck was a
right-wing conspiratorially minded
audience receptive to having their
attention focused on whatever the
scapegoat of the day or of the week was
you could sort of uh predict in some
general sense that Glenn Beck's
Relentless focus on the tides Foundation
might Inspire an act of violence against
the tides Foundation you couldn't
predict
that you know Joe Shmoe III from Florida
would be the guy to do the act of
violence but you could say we know that
some percentage of the population is uh
um suggestible in this way and we know
that Glenn Beck's audience is big enough
where if it's even only point one
percent of his audience that would hear
him talk about the tides foundation and
go and do something that means there's
at least a handful of people who would
go and do it and eventually this story
ended less tragically than it could have
ended which was California Highway
Patrol I again the details elude me but
pulled over a guy with guns in his car
going to the tides Foundation because
Glenn Beck had talked about it that's
stochastic terrorism it's not that Glenn
Beck directed in the way that you might
say okay you're my accomplice for this
crime go and do this thing I'm legally
liable okay I tell you to do it give you
the means give you the reasoning or what
the inspiration it's not legal liability
so we use the term stochastic terrorism
that's what we're dealing here with
Trump putting out what he claimed was
Barack Obama's home address you know I
used to think that
Trump winning the 2016 election was one
of the biggest disasters in American
history
I don't know that I've given it enough
credit it's probably more like in modern
world history the election of trump and
the cult status of trump as a leader to
at least tens of millions of people
quite frankly probably one of the worst
events one of the biggest disasters in
modern world history and interestingly
enough Trump wants more people out
protesting for him fortunately it
doesn't seem that many people are
willing and that's what I want to talk
about next there's a very interesting
report
related to a recent truth social post
from Donald Trump mediaite writes Trump
ramps up calls for Americans to hit the
streets on his behalf
do people even have a choice but to
protest and the article sort of points
at a recent truth Central post from
Donald Trump where he wrote naturally in
all capital letters as he tends to do
quote massive prosecutorial misconduct
is currently taking place in America the
weaponization of law enforcement cannot
be allowed to happen crime and inflation
are rampant our borders are open our
elections are rigged our economy is in
shambles by the way none of these things
are true
our energy Independence is gone our
quote leader is mercilessly mocked and
our country is being destroyed both
inside and out do the people of this
once great nation even have a choice but
to protest the potential Doom of the
United States of America 2024.
there are two competing big storylines
with Trump's requests and in some cases
demands that his followers go out and
protest out in public the first one is
even though January 6th went terribly
Trump is still suggesting to people that
they go out in protest this is reckless
this is self-centered egotistical and
narcissistic and all of those things
Trump doesn't care or is ignoring or has
forgotten or is indifferent to the fact
that the last time he convinced people
to go and protest about a thousand
people got arrested and charged with
various crimes and some people died okay
and it almost held up
it temporarily held up the um
what should be a peaceful transfer of
power in that case in 2021 between Trump
and Biden that's one story The Second
Story is that even though Trump's
followers uh I guess still support the
guy based on the polling that we're
looking at they don't seem very willing
to go out and protest now that may be
because they don't care enough to go out
and protest or it may be because they
they know what happened on January 6th
they don't want to end up in pre-trial
detention awaiting trial okay so but for
whatever reason Trump is struggling to
get people to go and protest for him you
might remember uh in late March the New
York Times uh wrote an article Trump
claims his arrest is imminent and calls
for protests echoing January 6th except
the protest didn't really happen there
was a small show of support at
Mar-A-Lago and then ultimately when
Trump was arrested and indicted both
times there were relatively small groups
of people who went out and wasn't even
totally clear that they cared really
that much you might remember that before
Donald Trump's second arrest as U.S news
reminds us Trump calls supporters to
action as he prepares for arraignment on
criminal charges in Miami again this was
for the second arrest in Miami we were
live on the ground there uh and there
really was not that much going on yes
some of them showed up but it was a lot
of media and a lot of sort of curious uh
rubberneckers who did not seem
particularly committed to protesting for
Trump and then shortly uh after the
first arrest there was this report from
PBS Trump's calls for protests failed to
gain traction ahead of anticipated
indictment so there is a very
interesting situation
where a guy that still has the devotion
of more than half of the Republican
electorate we have the polling Trump's
still polling at this point 53 percent
holding very steady this is exactly
where he was at the beginning of April
more or less
Trump's still the support and devotion
of more than half of the Republican
party but they either seem to know
better or aren't quite enough committed
that they are willing to go out and
protest that all being said as Trump's
trials move forward
if he's indicted a third time a fourth
time potentially if it starts to impact
Trump's ability to run his campaign as
the debates and everything get going of
all of which we'll be covering maybe his
followers will be more inspired to get
out there and protest if they do
remember my view on this is very
nonpartisan
um protest very patriotic and American
it's a form of speech Etc violence I do
not condone or defend and if they go
into law breaking
and violence then I will say throw the
book at him as uh they already should
know better based on January 6th we're
going to follow all of it but
interestingly nothing so far is moving
polling we've got the polling up on the
screen the purple line is Trump you did
see this Boost after the first
indictment but basically flat you see de
sanctimonious who lost a little support
after Trump's first indictment but is
more or less steady and then at the
bottom you've got the zero through sixes
the only guy who's seeing a little bit
of a bump lately is Mike Pence and I
actually have no opinion as to why that
is at six percent it doesn't really seem
like the guys got a path to the
nomination we have such a great program
for you today I'm glad you're here this
was a shortened week because because of
the Fourth of July next week is a full
robust thick and Meaty week of
programming make sure you're subscribed
on YouTube remember that the children's
critical thinking book continues to be
available at davidpackman.com book we
are up now over 500 copies sold it is an
incredible thing that is going on we'll
talk about all of it there will be time
for all of it we'll take a quick break
and be right back
often I have to wear shirts for a long
time before the material softens and
feels good on my skin but if you want a
t-shirt that's actually super soft right
when you open the package brand new
check out our sponsor Leisure of NYC
T-shirts from Leisure of NYC are made
with supima cotton that's an Ultra
Premium species of cotton known for
feeling better than any other t-shirt
Fabric and way more durable
under one percent of men's t-shirts are
made with supima cotton also check out
the boxer briefs made from moisture
wicking viscose from bamboo which will
bring you a level of comfort you didn't
even know was possible with underwear
these boxer briefs feel like air and
they don't Bunch up all of their
products are fair trade produced using
sustainable methods when you buy the
scratchy cheaply made t-shirts and
boxers you end up spending more in the
long run but once you do it right with
t-shirts and boxers that feel silky
smooth from day one they will last you
for years to come you'll get 15 off
everything in their store at
davidpackman.com
NYC the link is below
the David Pacman show continues to be a
community funded program you can support
our work of course by signing up on our
website joinpakman.com and getting
instant access to all of the great
member benefits I talk about all the
time I won't list them again you can use
the coupon code indicted again to get
yourself a discount also make sure
you're subscribed to the YouTube channel
you can pick up the kids critical
thinking book that is now available
great for ages 6 to 12 6 and 7 probably
with parents you know what I mean at
davidpackman.com book many ways to
support our work let's hear from some
people in the audience these are the
most important people without you there
is no show we take calls via Discord on
the Friday show at davidpackman.com
slash Discord and we will start today
with Chris from Massachusetts Chris what
is going on my friend
hi David it is so wonderful to finally
be able to speak with you I had two
quick questions that actually don't have
to do with politics to start us off sure
that's allowed
first um I know that you are a fan of
tango music of course I was wondering if
you were into any other forms of Latin
American music from other parts of the
world do you like salsa Mariachi any of
those you know I'm not huge on let me
put it this way I like all of it I just
don't know enough about it to be able to
name any artists it's sort of like I
know when I go to certain restaurants or
events they have music of all of these
styles that I like but it's not like I
take time out of my day to go and
investigate artists or bands or anything
like that but sure I mean listen other
than country and hardcore heavy metal uh
I'll go for most stuff you know
ah fantastic fantastic thank you and my
last quick question is
I loved him he was the best Chris asking
what happened to
Pedro
from
Colombia yeah we just haven't heard from
him in honestly it feels like years for
Chris
oh well that's all I have for you thank
you so much for taking my call all right
Chris from Massachusetts with a number
of questions in a number of languages
and we love to see it let's go to Harry
from Chicago Illinois Harry from Chicago
welcome to the David Pacman show how may
I serve you today sir
can you hear me yes
a lot excellent excellent so I used to
call in as uh Harry from Columbus I
don't know if you have any recollection
of that I've recently moved to Chicago
um you know after some brief inspiration
from you actually
wow I I hold on you moved from Columbus
to Chicago because of something I said
in part in part you know I wanted to
move anyway but you know just some stuff
that you said really put me over the
edge and why Chicago did have I sung its
Praises before
no I mean not necessarily Chicago so
much as getting out of a red State and
going into a blue State I gotcha I think
and are you enjoying that
yeah I am greatly I am I haven't driven
on a highway in like two weeks now I
think my brain is finally healing a
little bit that's good um but it's been
really good well to any extent that you
want to thank me I will accept the
praise thank you well I mean I know you
used to also live in Western
Massachusetts is that correct yeah
I went to college there do you know
about Holyoke yes yes I do
okay did you pronounce it Holyoke or
Holyoke no no no I you know I'm not into
this whole hoyoke thing I pronounce it
Holyoke now remember I'm from Argentina
and I only lived in that region for for
a time and never in Holyoke but I
pronounce it Holyoke
yeah it takes time to learn the language
like Amherst and uh okay uh so my my
question about politics after you know
last week's rulings all the bad scotus
rulings that in my opinion of course
um how do you feel about scotus it's not
it's something that it engages in
specifically is judicial review right uh
ultimately determined in I think was
Marbury V Madison way back when that
scotus could do this now other countries
other democracies they don't have this
kind of judicial review
um do you consider it something bad do
you think more Justice is is the problem
people on the left have criticized that
yeah I think judicial review is needed
to be a check and balance what do you
what do you think about you know
judicial review of law that has passed
so listen obviously I am not a legal
expert so I speak to the political
implications here I do believe that
there is a degree to which judicial
review meaning the power of a court to
say this law that was passed no good
it's unconstitutional to some degree it
can be undemocratic the nine justices
are not elected and they can say well
we're overriding the popular sovereignty
of states and okay but sometimes they
may be making the right decision and we
might want it you can say judicial
review is unreliable because as you're
pointing out it depends to some degree
on personal views and biases we know
that a left-wing Supreme Court versus a
right-wing Supreme Court is likely to
come down in different places on many
important and controversial decisions
you can argue that judicial review is
unnecessary in that there are better
ways to protect certain rights either by
referenda or media scrutiny or you know
but but at the same time sometimes you
can't there's the argument that it's
counterproductive because then when
there's judicial review that goes
counter to the party that is in power
there's a backlash effect where the
party in power says all right well we're
going to now figure out some other way
to do the thing so that we can act you
know like Biden figuring out a different
way to do student loans so I think that
there are really good arguments against
judicial review but where I am trying to
focus most based on my audience and what
I do
is
we we have to remember
that if Hillary Clinton had defeated
Donald Trump a lot of what we have seen
from this Supreme Court would never have
happened it is undeniable at this point
this is not to shame anybody this is not
to insult anybody I am doing a show that
is based around electoral politics we
have an election coming up we need to
beat people over the head metaphorically
with the reality that we may again have
this sort of situation depending on who
wins in November of 2024 and that
everything that's happened the justices
that are now on the court Roe v Wade all
of these different things if Hillary
Clinton gets to put a few people on the
court instead of Donald Trump based on
winning in 2016 we have a completely
different Supreme Court it's not a
solution it doesn't answer a lot of
these questions but it's a reminder
about the importance of these elections
yeah I I agree that I don't think I
don't have any delusions that judicial
review is going away anytime soon
correct and I I agree if you know four
out of nine of the justices are you know
were either stolen elected from
presidents who didn't win the popular
vote I agree that electoralism is
probably the best way to be to beat the
monster of the scotus even though in the
200 year history of our country it's
been mostly a right-wing institution
that has dominated us you know with all
that in mind we can still hope uh thanks
for taking my call David all right Harry
from Chicago great to hear from you just
a reminder for people waiting to chat
with me you must have your name and
location in your nickname if you just
have one or the other or just a nickname
or that sort of thing uh you are not
going to be called on it's sort of just
like can folks follow basic directions
we're trying to have some filter so we
try to get quality calls so we do uh we
do enforce that we do enforce that let's
go to Vitali from Iowa Vitale from Iowa
welcome to the David packman show
hi David can you hear me yes I can
all right uh so I have uh you might have
gotten this question before but
um
I am sort of along the lines uh where
you are I would consider myself more of
a Social Democrat and uh I
I've encountered a lot of my peers who
are more along the lines of uh
Democratic socialists anarcho Communists
Etc and uh
there's a lot of infighting uh I even
get called right wing sometimes okay so
I was wondering uh what you would say to
that and how to stop all this infighting
that's going on well these are two very
different questions if I as a Social
Democrat were called right wing I would
do what I already do which is to say
tell me which positions of mine are
right wing and that usually grinds the
conversation to a halt because it's very
hard to name positions of mine that are
right wing so at the individual level of
Italy I when people call you right wing
because you're a Social Democrat and not
a socialist ask them to enumerate your
right wing positions you know what I'm
saying
sure sure now in terms of more generally
about reducing the infighting I have
absolutely no idea
um the the reality is that
the infighting on the right
I believe is more uh prevalent right now
than than on the left even though it's
very popular to say the left has all
this infighting it's true you can find
people on the left who if you don't
subscribe to every idea about all of
these issues what what usually with
cultural issues there is a slice of the
left which will say you're not really on
the left but it's actually relatively
small whereas on the right the Maga
versus anti-maga stuff is really ugly
and we'll see to what extent it's
destructive but it's lost them a bunch
of Elections so far so I mean listen
it'd be great if the the entire left can
get on the same page and then we all
sing Kumbaya and all of this stuff the
reality is that there's a spectrum of
the left from Center left Democrats all
the way out to you know leninist left
and revolutionary left and socialist and
all these different things
if we're really honest most of the left
is on the same page when it comes to a
particular election who are we better
off with and that doesn't mean some
people don't stay home or protest mode
or whatever the case may be but I
actually think the left is quite United
all right
um yeah thank you for your Insight David
I just want to say um I've been a
subscriber for a few years now and you
were actually uh you helped uh pulled me
out of the Maga right so I just want to
say thank you sir well thank you for
your service I appreciate it yes all
right there goes Vitale from Iowa with a
very powerful declaration let's go to
Pam from Florida Pam from Florida
Welcome to the David Pacman show what's
on your mind today and please unmute
yourself Pam
Pam please unmute yourself so that we
can talk you are muted and it is you're
doing and you're doing
yeah hi hey David I am so happy that uh
Howard Stern is now listening to you yes
I I had written him a million times but
um anyway I'm here in Florida I can see
all the stuff that DeSantis is doing
that isn't necessarily on the national
stage as far as insurance the issues and
insurance and everything else I know how
bad he is and um
I don't know if Trump does not wind up
running which I think is slim but if he
doesn't if he doesn't win the um the or
if he doesn't get to uh compete in the
primary do you think hold on a second
let me Pam let me so Trump is running
you're saying if he loses the primary or
if he ends up I'm sorry if he doesn't
even get to the primary like if he drops
out before the voting starts right
gotcha do you think do you think the
Santa says a chance yeah I mean listen
if we just look at the math if Trump's
gone DeSantis is the guy who seems best
positioned in my head I'm thinking you
know if Trump ends up having to dump
because of whatever reason
maybe Republicans could like be sane
again and select Chris Christie but I
don't think that they're going to I
think just looking at the numbers
DeSantis is best positioned if Trump
fails right I see that and it's it's uh
very scary
um and what about the Mages if Trump
isn't in the race that's a really good
question because Trump's attacked Ron
DeSantis significantly right so there's
a really good question which is if Trump
bails what percentage of the current
Trump support goes to DeSantis or do
they go to someone else or do they not
even participate I don't know the answer
to that right now Pam
okay okay
yeah it's just he's just he scares me
more than Trump I never thought I'd say
that I agree no I mean we had this on
the Monday show the voicemail was about
this I think that he's he's less visibly
Bonkers but he's less incompetent and
would get more crazy things done so I
think the santis is super scary
and has a just a like determination that
his way like you see it in his eyes like
he just you know I know he's doing it
for to win over that that sector that
voting um population but also it just
she's just she's handmaid's tale and
it's just it's a real big threat but
anyway thank you so much
thank you Pam from Florida great to hear
from you let's just take a very quick
break and then we'll go back to the
phone so uh just hang on if you're
waiting to talk to me we'll take a very
quick break and then be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
let's go back to Discord and speak to a
few more people we do take calls on the
Friday show at davidpackman.com
Discord let's go
um why don't we go we go next to Rolando
from Miami Florida Rolando welcome to
the program what is on your mind today
hello can you hear me yes
all right perfect hi David uh good to
talk to you likewise I've been a long
time uh listener and so uh my question
funny enough is kind of picky backing
off of the previous caller and some of
the discourse around DeSantis and kind
of his threat on the national level as
president
um or I guess at least versus Trump
um I kind of questioned that just a
little bit I do agree that he's been
very effective in Florida but I guess my
question is how much of that is because
of the uh legislative environment in
Florida being that he has both the uh
the Florida House and Senate being able
to pass some of his agendas I kind of
question maybe how he'll be able to
stack up against a lot of national
players
um
especially like in the House and Senate
and even like his overall demeanor uh I
have a lot of questions on that what's
kind of your take I am 100 in agreement
with you I think that in a number of
ways DeSantis isn't ready for prime time
I don't think DeSantis has what it takes
from from a campaign standpoint to run a
national campaign particularly against a
guy who is so captivating to to many
Republicans as is Trump apparently uh I
don't think he has what it takes there
and it's also extraordinarily difficult
if we Flash Forward and imagine that Ron
DeSantis wins the primary and defeats
Joe Biden and becomes president of the
United States it is really difficult to
imagine uh DeSantis as a serious player
who's going to get major legislation
done I I I'm as skeptical as you are and
listen we're just making predictions we
could be totally wrong but I don't see
the guy as having what it takes
sure yeah and then also seeing recently
now a lot of Republican donors are
pulling back from him yeah uh other
people in the party seem to be reluctant
about him as well of course that could
all change if somehow he does become the
the primary candidate uh people could
kind of
come around and coalesce around him uh
just to get that win in the white house
but yeah I don't know uh I
despite kind of all the the hype around
him I think it seems as at least right
now is going to kind of fall short and I
know I'm my money right now is going to
be Trump versus versus Biden yeah I mean
listen if I were betting today I think
that that's certainly the most likely
outcome with the caveat that there are
unknowns Trump could get arrested and
indicted a third time a fourth time
maybe it pulls him off the campaign
Trail who knows but it would take a
major event right not not the normal
sort there's no attack ad DeSantis can
run that's going to put him ahead of
trump right now that sort of thing
sure and do you think uh I mean I've
been taking a look at polling but how do
you think
uh I guess DeSantis versus Biden what
are those what are those odds looking
like
well according to the polling DeSantis
does better against Biden than Trump so
like if we're just super like empirical
about it there's an argument to be made
that Biden would be better off running
against Trump than he would against
DeSantis so that that's the only data
point I have
all right sounds good well David thanks
so much for your time I appreciate uh
you speaking with me and uh you know
good luck with the rest of the show
thanks so much there is Rolando from
Miami great to hear from you very much
appreciate it let's go next to Stephen
from Tacoma Stephen welcome to the
program what's going on today
uh yes sir can you hear me yes
um yes I wanted to talk about
um uh the thing around RFK Jr right now
and uh how he's doing so well in the
polls right now and um how much of that
do you think is um not really his
policies but mainly his right name
recognition as a Kennedy I think that
the main name recognition is a part of
it
um but also uh it it his I've seen some
breakdowns and his support seems to have
spiked in particular actually among
Republicans interestingly enough and
um the other thing is if you go back and
look at look at his polling I have it on
the screen in front of me in early May
and late April let me let me say it more
chronologically in late April early May
there are a bunch of polls that have RFK
around 20 percent like there's an
Emerson poll that had him at 21 a fox
poll that had him at 19 a CNN poll at
20. now he rarely even hits 15. like
there's one poll that has him at 17 but
now he's as low as eight and typically
in the low to mid teens he overall RFK
actually seems to have lower polling
support today than he did several months
ago so I don't know I don't really make
much of it one way or the other I think
that it's potentially a spoiler campaign
I think there's a lot of Mag of people
that like it because it's chaotic and it
might hurt Joe Biden but you know I've
talked about it I I feel like it's I've
struggled Stephen to find the right
amount to talk about RFK when I don't
talk about and people say I'm ignoring
him because I'm scared when I do talk
about him people write to me say David
this guy's got no shot and he's cuckoo
why are you even talking about him you
know if you're polling 14 in the
Democratic primary I think it makes
sense that I talk about you a little bit
but I don't find the entire thing super
impressive
okay yeah because I figured that a lot
of his name right a lot of his name
recognition was helping him in the polls
and yeah whatever wait the Kennedy name
still has but it might I think for I
think for really anybody under maybe the
age of 40 that's kind of a historical
name that's just kind of my two cents on
it but as I can see some of the polls
he's starting to go down people are
starting to notice that he's getting
more support from like Steve Bannon and
all the Maga people and people are
starting to figure out they're looking
beyond the Kennedy name and realizing oh
wait this guy is he's he's a um I'm not
going to say the term but he's trying to
mess up the potential primary or
potential uh Biden vote yeah I mean
listen we'll see where it goes but my
money is that it doesn't have a lot of
oxygen left to grab
yeah I figured that too all right all
right thank you David all right thank
you very much there's Stephen from
Tacoma very very important uh subject
matter being discussed in General on
today's program and I appreciate that
why don't we go next to
oh I don't know how about David from
Regina Regina
Saskatchewan
Regina actually is that true that's how
it's pronounced
yes it is actually there's a song online
called experience Regina Jimmy Fallon
actually has uh he's covered that before
but David welcome to the program
yeah thanks for having me um yeah I
guess my question today I've been you
know you had a caller a few weeks back
who was talking about uh gender and and
sex and I feel like something's
happening a lot where the right is
conflating these two things a lot right
like they don't understand the
difference between biological sex and
and gender expression right yep you know
while they're related they're not the
same thing so I guess my question is
like how the hell do we even start to
have that description right like I feel
like
we can't even have a discussion about
the issue without people understanding
what that even means if that makes sense
yeah I don't know like I I feel like so
the call in the call you're thinking of
I made an attempt to try to explain to
the caller who maybe was just unwilling
rather than unable to see I gave the
example of The Rock and then the fashion
designer Isaac Mizrahi and I think that
in a respectful way I explained you
understand these are both males right
we're talking about biological males
they were born male Etc we're talking
they're both male The Rock expresses
gender in a much more stereotypically
masculine way whereas Isaac Mizrahi uh
expresses gender in a much more feminine
way like you so the idea was to get him
to think okay right penis penis I see
that and then here's one presentation
and here's another presentation oh
there's more than just the genitalia
like I I tried you know I I think
sometimes it's it's like you've got to
use examples like that not to maybe get
them to think about these things but I
agree with you a lot of them do they
they don't seem to want to get it
honestly
well and that's just it right I think
and I think honestly like
if they would just take even just like
an introductory level course in like any
of these social science topics like
we've talked about this for decades and
decades and like there's not there's
really no debate about the difference
between these things anymore right so
but it's scary stuff like it has a real
impact and you know we're definitely
frightened up here in Canada watching
your Supreme Court do all these weird
things so
um yeah I hope I hope you guys can turn
that around with the next election for
sure well let's hope so we are I am on
board with uh with your now how is is
this an issue that's even really
discussed where you are or is it just
like people don't really talk about this
um you know I'm in Saskatchewan and
we're kind of the most right-wing place
in Canada so um like it's conservative
Haven here
um but as a country as a whole I I mean
it's discussed and there's like kind of
a fringe movement of people who want to
do the whole Mega thing here
um but I would say as a majority I don't
see that happening I don't see that
movement uh getting a lot of traction
um even even here in the conservative
kind of Bible Belt of Canada it's it's
while it's more popular here some of
these ideas they're still not getting
enough traction to like influence a lot
of policy and and that kind of thing so
I think I'm hoping we're safe I mean I I
knock on wood right so
I hope that that's the case David I
appreciate the call
yeah thanks for having me all right
great to hear from our friendly
neighbors to the north of course let's
go to Devin from Virginia Devin from
Virginia welcome to the David packman
show
oh thank you
um yeah I just want to talk about my
state and kind of like how it's not
really doing great uh especially about
them unfortunate I have to show my ID to
access an adult website called uh
PornHub and
um now there are loopholes to this like
I could simply turn off my Wi-Fi and I
can access it so it's a very flawed
system well wait if you turn off Wi-Fi
how do you access a website do you don't
you need the internet connection
uh with my data on my phone
I see what you're saying yeah so yeah so
it's the big loopholes and like VPN so
it's not really effective and it's like
very dangerous right if you show your
ideal porno like it can easily be your
ID can be stolen so it's just uh really
dumb so have you and your friends sort
of like uh figured out how to get around
this ID requirement
uh yeah yeah like I said VPN is done
like search like uh thing on Google when
it happened
um and others as well too so yeah it's
like it's not very effective it's more
dangerous for people and for children
it's just like I I don't know if you say
culture War protected kids type stuff I
don't know no thinking bigger picture
other than difficulty access slight
difficulty accessing porn what else
don't you like that's going on in
Virginia
um let's see I would say our governor
like he uh he won based on us you know
saying uh critical race theories in our
schools yeah and that boosted him and he
won based off that and I was really
disappointed with Virginians uh for sure
because I thought would be smarter than
that I guess not
um yeah yeah I know it's just
it's you know it's it's tough you know
you thinking about moving
um yeah when I'm able to have the funds
for it yeah for sure I would definitely
like to move maybe Colorado right boys
like the cold so yeah well Devin we're
sending you our best all right
thanks I appreciate a lot all right
Devin from Virginia sticking it out he's
figured out how to get the porn but
still struggling with the governor
that's uh
that's a situation that's for sure let's
go next to Ryan from Auburn New York
Ryan welcome to the David Pacman show
what can I do for you today
Ryan please accept my invitation to join
me for a discussion
oh can you hear me now yes I can
hey David um I had a question on AI I
actually was scrolling through some
shorts today and I got this weird ad and
it was a fake celebrity endorsement from
um you know one of these celebrity chefs
and it was obvious to me that it was AI
but how long do you think it's going to
be before AI before we can't tell you
know before someone says Hey I want a
David Pacman endorsement and I'm just
gonna fake it you know with AI I think
that for the tech I think the technology
for it to be indistinguishable is
probably already there and I think it's
a matter of 12 to 18 months because
before it becomes more widely available
uh affordable for pedestrian use all the
time to trick people in the way you're
saying maybe a couple of years but I
think it's basically here I think it's
almost there right now
yeah I think you're right and I think
one one thing I heard on this on one of
your your take like one person was
saying you know there's there's already
people doing deep fakes of jokes with
Joe Biden and and Trump and they're like
playing video games and trash talking
each other yep but and and you can tell
that they're fake but um if someone had
like a full Biden speech like a pre like
uh you know addressing the nation and he
just slipped in one or two sentences
that would be probably very easy to get
by don't you think oh yeah because you'd
have to go back and sort of watch the
entire speech to even see is this clip
genuinely from that speech or not I mean
this stuff can get very dangerous I
don't I'm not I don't yet know what the
solution is to be honest but it can it
could be very effectively dangerous
or dangerously effective depending on
your view
yeah and a lot of people have a lot of
views about how AI is going to destroy
us I don't think it's going to destroy
us as far as like you know Ultron from
you know marvel or whatever I think it's
more like it's going to give us the
ability to destroy ourselves or not be
able to believe anybody or anything 100
and and part of that is quite huxleyan
in terms of the the view of Aldous
Huxley and Brave New World which is you
don't really need to censor just put out
so much nonsense that nobody will even
know what to pay attention to what to
believe Etc and that's a very very scary
situation
I agree 100
um that was the only question I had for
today but uh really appreciate your
thoughts all right thanks Ryan very much
appreciate it and thanks to everybody
who called in we'll take calls again but
for now we'll take a quick break and
then be right back with more
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's dive
into head first the Friday Feed Bag AKA
Friday feedback also known as really
ignorant people write to me and I
struggle to explain the things that they
say we're going to start today with
someone named Zoya zorai zoyara
zavova
who says you mud be do lonely in your
dungeon I know it's your job to talk bad
about Trump Republican conservatives
that's how you make views but does it
truly bring you happiness when was the
last time you felt free peaceful and
joyful go to church this Sunday seek and
you will find the capital T truth oh boy
it's hard to take this seriously
and engage with it in anything
approximating a serious manner
but
um it actually does bring me happiness
to be able to and this is no disrespect
to anyone who likes it but to be able to
not have some boss waiting for me who
says sir we start at 905 and you didn't
get here until 908 this morning and to
be able to talk about or focus on
whatever I want any day if I want to
take time off I take time off like that
it really brings me happiness to not
only have that work schedule and
situation but also to be able to have
such a great Community present company
of course accept it as far as this
message is concerned uh of people who I
engage with and it really does bring me
happiness so I know that that's of
course the number one concert concern of
zoyara zavova but uh no need to worry
about me thank you very much DW says
Pac-Man can you please explain explain
why you never talk about bidens and
Clinton's unclassified documents because
they're not classified I'm guessing
that's an error only a president can
declassify documents not a vice
president or a secretary of state I
wonder why most commenters on this
channel are only concerned about Trump's
actions could it be because they will
let it slide if they agree with the
person's politics no no no
how many times have I talked about
Biden's documents and Hillary Clinton's
documents at this point dozens and
dozens the reality is the facts are
different the way our correspondent Luke
Beasley explained to some of those
magadonians magapotamians earlier this
week in Pickens South Carolina the facts
are different Joe Biden had a small
number of documents they were
immediately returned when found there
was no alleged obstruction there was no
alleged witness tampering there was no
showing the documents to random people
on the Portico of Mar-A-Lago or whatever
okay there was none of that Hillary
Clinton yes she was careless that was
the determination but an investigation
determined no crimes were committed I
talk about it it's just that it's a
different set of facts what this person
really should be saying is I don't care
that it's a different of facts I want
Biden and Hillary to be indicted to just
because of their partisan uh uh uh
affiliation I don't want it to just be
Trump well maybe Trump's the only one
who committed crimes have to consider
that have to consider that uh next
person who goes by the username life is
a gift cherish every moment all right
says I was born in the United States of
America in 1950 for most of my life I
thought of myself as a patriot and I
admired and respected others who
referred to themselves as Patriots that
all changed on January 6 2021 now I am
very cautious around anyone who calls
themselves a patriot if this is
patriotism I am very concerned for the
future of the United States of America
well of course they're correct and I've
spoken about this before the right has
obtained a monopoly on patriotism not on
patriotism the thing on patriotism the
word and we've spoken before about the
difference between patriotism and
Nationals and we've done that we've gone
down this rabbit hole before
it is not
a uniquely right-wing thing and I would
argue there is nothing patriotic about
the modern Maga movement it is patriotic
to say hey you know what we're Americans
we're not going to let anyone standard
of living fall below a certain level
it's patriotic to say we'll make sure
everybody has housing
and Food and Health Care wow that's
patriotism okay that is just as valid as
whatever cockamami version of patriotism
these people on the right ascribe to
that word
uh Stephen Rhoden noticing what's been
happening on our tick tocks and says 500
000 on Tick Tock but how many on truth
truth essential yeah uh listen we're not
we're not on Truth Central or truth
social but I have to tell you what is
happening on Tick Tock is unbelievable
now I know Tick Tock may be banned and
all these different things listen I get
it okay I have no control over that to
the extent that it's a platform on on
which we can get our message out
I think we're up to 530 000 followers on
Tick Tock much of it because of the
great work of my colleague John in
helping us build that platform much of
it because of the shift to short form
content
I I know that this is really difficult
to believe
we now are seeing as many monthly views
on Tick Tock as we get on our YouTube
channel and we've been on Tick Tock like
a year and a half and we've been on
YouTube more than a decade and the
YouTube channel is Big okay it is
stunning the growth that we're having
there and the important thing is we are
getting the message out at this point I
think I get recognized on the street
as much for hey you're the tick tock guy
uh as as I do for YouTube it's an
incredible thing Colin Peter Kowski
says without Christianity you have chaos
are you blind you know whenever I see
comments like these the same thought
always occurs to me which is are you
telling me that the only thing keeping
you
from acting in a disgusting or criminal
way or immoral way
is your belief that Jewish Carpenter
Jesus died and was resurrected and was
born to a virgin and there was this Ark
and eating shrimp is bad and like you're
saying if you didn't have that you'd be
out murdering people for people to say
we would have no moral compass if we
didn't have God telling us what to do
you're saying the only thing keeping you
from murdering people
is that God says it's not a good thing
to do that's scary that's really really
scary and so I struggle with this type
of statement listen if the community and
the idea of something bigger than
yourself from religion is a positive
thing for you and it helps you to
connect with those around you and have a
optimistic outlook on life oh absolutely
there is no denying the importance of
religion
separating of course from specific
religious beliefs there's no way that we
can minimize some of the positive things
about religious community in history and
negative things as well we can talk
about but without Christianity you have
chaos
very very tough very very tough and by
the way
countries with very little Christianity
often have very little crime which would
be another way to say they're not
particularly chaotic Libby Shipman
commented on Facebook and says the thing
about Chris Christie is that no matter
how good he campaigns it's obvious that
he cannot control his eating so how can
he be trusted to control anything else
and Linda Anderson says that is a
ridiculous comment yeah I mean listen
it's a pretty stupid thing to say
he can't control his eating so what he
he has a worse you'd ra you'd sooner
give Trump the nuclear codes because
Chris Christie eats a lot I mean it just
it's it's it's quite a strange
non-sequitur it really is
um it you know it's less about refuting
the specifics of this but more about
you're allowed to decide who to vote for
using absolutely any rubric or standard
and many of these people do they're the
message we should get is that there are
people like Libby
who would say I guess I'd rather Trump
because Chris Christie is eats a lot by
the way Trump's also obese which is a
whole other story but maybe maybe Libby
prefers
I don't know who's thin Vivek ramaswami
because Vivek can control the amount he
eats and Chris Christie can't it the
this is what we're up against and we are
much better off just finding people and
getting them to vote rather than
convincing people like Libby to change
their minds because they're probably not
going to a Reddit user knower of stuff
remember the David Pacman show subreddit
is at uh davidpackman.com Reddit knower
of stuff says are we at a point where
conservatives are simultaneously buying
and trying to ban electric vehicles to
own the libs like wouldn't it be
surprising if you had conservative Elon
Musk Fanatics who bought Teslas
partially because they think it will
trigger liberals by supporting a must
company but on the other hand you still
have most conservatives who are
anti-environmentalist and hate electric
vehicles like Marjorie Taylor green who
calls it calls them a threat to the
country lawmaker in Wyoming who pretty
much tried to ban them basically to own
the lips yeah it's it's it reminds me of
the vaccine
Donald Trump deserves all of the credit
for developing these vaccines which
don't work are killing people and I
absolutely will not take Trump deserves
credit for that he's way better than Joe
Biden what wait so is the vaccine good
or bad doesn't matter it is a very
similar thing with Twitter it's easier
because it's like okay Twitter is less
about lifestyle it's less about broader
political belief it's like you're on
Twitter or you're not you like Elon
musk's handling of it or you don't the
electric vehicle one is interesting
because a lot of these right-wingers
hate electric vehicles
but at the same time they do think that
it is an easy way now to trigger the
left by supporting Elon Musk so maybe
what they'll do is they'll go and buy a
Tesla to support musk but then they'll
burn it I don't know or something like
that like the people who are shooting
Bud Lights with with shotguns it's all
very very weird all right lastly Big D
says to me on Instagram
this guy is on the payroll of the left
don't believe him he has not talked a
word about the hunter Biden indictment
thus guy is sketchy sketchy is
misspelled well Big D couple different
things I've been talking about Hunter
Biden for years I was away at a wedding
the week that Hunter struck a plea deal
and I have spoken about it since
multiple times so every single one of
these claims is false by the way I'm on
the payroll of the left if by the
payroll of the left you mean that there
are people on the left who get
memberships on my website and support my
work guilty as charged if you mean
payroll of the left as in the Democratic
establishment the DNC George Soros or
whoever are funding this program the
answer is they are not and I challenge
you to present a shred of evidence a
shred of evidence for a decade these
folks have been saying that you must be
on the payroll of the DNC not even a
Democrat
why would they pay me doesn't make a lot
of sense MSNBC must be paying you why
would MSNBC pay people who aren't even
on their Network very strange not much
of an understanding of how
anything Works quite frankly
uh find some kind of proof that any of
these organizations are paying me and I
will say you got me you got me I did
everything right and they indicted me
okay I will say it here uh all right we
have a fantastic bonus show for you sign
up at joinpakman.com folks in all
seriousness the children's critical
thinking book is available
for pre-order on Kindle and in paperback
right now I hold in front of me proof
number one print this is the first proof
okay this is an historic item uh go to
davidpackman.com book donate them to
your kids class bring them around to
school libraries
uh give them as gifts
this is really something special that
we're doing davidpackman.com book we'll
see you on the bonus show if you're not
on the bonus show then I'll see you back
here Monday
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors it is hard to
find comfortable t-shirts shirts made of
supima cotton are the softest you will
find under one percent of t-shirts are
made with supima cotton and Leisure of
NYC is the place to find them you'll get
15 off their silky smooth t-shirts and
boxers at davidpackman.com
NYC the link is down below